suburbios enteros se han inundado debido
a las lluvias torrenciales en sydney
australia las autoridades dieron la voz
de alarma ordenando la evacuación de
miles de personas mientras que una presa
a 62 km de la mayor ciudad del país ha
comenzado a desbordarse
los servicios de emergencia rescataron
al menos unas 29 personas y han recibido
más de 1400 llamadas
facing ahora nos enfrentamos a peligros
en múltiples frentes inundaciones
repentinas inundaciones fluviales y
erosión costera esta es una situación de
emergencia que pone en peligro la
diversión en marzo inundaciones
similares causaron la muerte de 20
personas en sydney mientras tanto japón
se enfrenta a una ola de calor las
temperaturas en tokio alcanzaron máximos
históricos de más de 35 grados durante
nueve días consecutivos en algunas
partes del país se han alcanzado máximas
de 40 todo ello en un momento en el que
el país atraviesa la temporada de
lluvias y suele experimentar
temperaturas más suaves la cara que hace
mucho calor no puedo dejar de sudar
no estamos acostumbrados a que haga
tanto calor como en los últimos días
todo ello en un momento en el que la
nación atraviesa la temporada de lluvias
y suele experimentar temperaturas más
suaves el clima extremo también está
afectando a china el tifón saba ha
golpeado hong kong y el sur del país con
vientos de más de 120 kilómetros por
hora en la provincia de guandong esta
fábrica se ha visto muy afectada por el
temporal pero es en el mar que rodea
hong kong donde los daños han sido más
importantes el tifón partió en dos este
barco a pesar de la intervención de los
servicios de emergencia 27 personas han
desaparecido